sylvie tiene cáncer de mama después de
que le extirparan dos tumores comenzó su
quimioterapia las sesiones en el
hospital son frecuentes por lo que tiene
que superar su miedo al coronavirus las
ama comen aquí tenemos 16 puede pagarlas
me preocupaba me preguntaba si no podía
recibir la quimioterapia en casa trabajo
en un gabinete de enfermería
sé que hay quimioterapia en casa pero la
doctora de herbel me dijo que no era
posible que las primeras quimioterapias
no se hacen en casa entonces no tuve
elección ella me dijo que debía
continuar con el tratamiento así que
aquí vamos tenemos que salvar nuestras
vidas aunque sepamos que hay un virus
circulando quizás que no todos los
pacientes superan esta ansiedad muchos
tienen miedo de desplazarse y prefieren
suspender controles vitales algunas
camas permanecen vacías los oncólogos
están muy preocupados
y si de repente paramos los tratamientos
el riesgo es que la enfermedad empeore y
esto puede desencadenar la aparición de
metástasis u otros signos de avance de
la enfermedad
antes de la pandemia se realizaban 160
operaciones diarias en estos quirófanos
el habitual movimiento en esta unidad ha
cambiado por el de pasillos fantasma
solo se programan 25 operaciones diarias
muchos pacientes prefieren correr el
riesgo de esperar antes que extirpar un
tumor ya los critic las ocasiona por eso
que hay porque con usados hemos tenido
que encontrar lugares para estos
pacientes para operar para atenderles
automáticamente hemos acumulado retrasos
tenemos un personal de enfermería
cansado y vamos a tener un flujo de
pacientes vamos a poder cubrir esta
demanda haremos todo lo posible pero no
será fácil
a séptimo porque más allá del cobi 19 el
cáncer continúa siendo una de las
primeras causas de muerte en el mundo